in science we often need to deal with
some very large numbers for example the
mass of the Sun that is the mass of the
Sun a - followed by 30 zeros in units of
kilograms that is two thousand billion
billion billion kilograms there has got
to be a better way to write that can you
imagine if there wasn't and so we find
that the mass of the Sun is 2 0 0 0 0 0
0 0 0 0 yes sorry could you repeat that
I was with you up to - 0 0 0 0 0 it was
a 2 0 0 so to represent large numbers
easily we use something called
scientific notation scientific notation
takes advantage of powers of 10 for
example 10 to the power of 2 means take
2 tens and multiply them together and
you get 100 10 to the power of 3 means
multiply three tens together you get a
thousand 10 to the power of four 10 to
the power of four means take four tens
multiply them together and you get
10,000 so you should notice a pattern
developing when it's 10 to the power of
2 our final answer has a 1 followed by
two zeros it's 10 to the power of 3
has a one followed by three zeros ten to
the power of four again four zeros so if
we wanted to represent the mass of the
Sun in scientific notation we would need
30 zeros so we represent that using 10
to the power of 30 this means we're
multiplying 10 by itself 30 times which
gives us a 1 followed by 30 zeros but
the mass of the Sun is actually twice
that it's 2 followed by 30 zeros so we
can multiply 2 by 10 to the 30 in units
of kilograms and that is the mass of the
Sun it's a lot easier to write and it
takes up much less space on the page the
other problem is we have to deal with
some very tiny numbers for example the
mass of a proton is that is the mass of
a proton zero point and then there's 26
zeros and then 1 6 7 3 kilograms a truly
tiny number so how do we deal with this
again it's using a similar trick if we
raise 10 to the power of minus 1 it
means divided by 10 not multiplied by 10
so this means divided by 10 which gives
you 0.1 10 to the power of minus 2 means
divided by 10 twice which gives us zero
point zero one one hundredth 10 to the
power of minus 3 means divided by 10
three times or 0.001 so again you see a
pattern developing the exponent here
tells you the number of places to the
right of the decimal that the one is so
in this case 10 to the minus 2 the one
is two places to the right of the
decimal here 10 to the minus 3 the one
is three places to the right of the
decimal so in this case I have a one
that is actually 20
seven places to the right of the decimal
so I can write the mass of a proton as
one point six seven three times ten to
the minus 27 kilograms and this 10 to
the minus 27 has the function of putting
this number one point six seven three
twenty seven decimal places to the right
of the decimal point so as a challenge
questions see if you've understood it if
the Sun were made entirely of protons
how many protons would there be in the
Sun